Mark: THE CACK RACKER!
Bob: Why are you allowed to call a ship the Unyielding Fist?
Bob: But you're not allowed to call it the Cock Rocker. I feel like FISTING (ok i see you bob ;))
Mark: Okay. Everybody cross your fingers for some good frame rates.
Mark: Hey, I got decent frames guys! :D
Wade: HOW DO I GO
FORWARD?! (oh wade same)
Mark: You x 2 (studders) start!
Mark: You push.. uh... FIGURE IT OUT!
Wade: "W" DOES NOT WORK!
Mark: Smack some button with SOMETHING and then do that. (10/10 teaching skillz)
Jack: SMASH THE LIKE BUTTON *laughter*
Wade: We're not moving, but- Mark: we are not moving. Bob: YEAH TURN LEFT. Mark: Oh, we're moving Wade: FULL SPEED AHEAD BOYS!
Wade: We are descending. Mark: Why?
Jack: I'm on fire! Mark: there's a lot of ships like a lot of them Bob: turn right turn right you gotta turn right Wade.
Wade: Alright turning right. Full speed right Jack: TURN FUCKING RIGHT! Left, left, down and left Mark: You're doing great, your doing great Wade!
Jack: down, down, down, down a fraction, down a smidge, down a tad.
Mark: one smidge please, a smidget
Jack: ok I need some left.
Wade: LEFT Mark: there, YEAH
Mark: Good Wade. Wade: who's your daddy Captain? ;) Mark: Goo- oh don't we don't need to know that.....
Bob: Wow that got really creepy. Wade: I thought we had a thing going. Mark: no, we didn't not that thing.
Jack: Wha- how? Why? What? When? Wade: I misinterpreted the rules..
Jack: Of basic human interaction? Wade: Yes. (good job Wade) We're den-sen-den to get to them
Mark: We're dense...wha? (confused markimoo)
Dependent weird [in] song for Dim sum. We're dumpling and we're doubling down dumplings. We're dumplings besides
I won't screw up this mining outpost
[alright], you're not giving it okay? Oh, I know all right. Well. It's on the other side wait, so if you could just like oh
We're moving forward [vance] [all] right [done]. You gotta write more
You're down a little more
More like down and to the right there we go
[I] feel like you guys are judging your good old captain
[no], no no no no no no no I feel like this good old captain is learning
Maybe it's not so easy, and he should have cut me a little baby
Patent [thing] [for] [him] to be on fire. We're going to hit a wall after wall
catalyst know
What I say left. I mean like 20 bit 23rd, okay, all right, okay turn right turn right turn right turn, right?
Oh, shit. My gun is now activated my [super-nice] my special is up
Wearing wait. I'm gonna get you. I don't think the [wait]. There's a special knot repair. [oh]
That explains a lot
All right
Oh boy. Oh boy. Everything's on fire. I regret. I tire
We're we're gonna be rejoice over shine right? We're getting a mapper shot
[me] [who] it who's who are we why are we who and why aren't we shouldn't work because Horton here - who [won] [-]
[goddammit]. Go left Captain let it be I'm sun Rapidly losing Faith [in] you can
Hard gray laughs laughs laughs laughs laughs [fight] you what left left left left is that our battle cry laughs oh?
No, no, no no no no [fly] by their corpse - shut up
Let's go, don't go fucker guys. We're just gonna sit right here that love it in here is a bad idea. Oh
All right, [no] better than your captain. I think I don't know you're beautiful
You're welcome. Oh hell the guns are down gotcha. Thanks, man. Thanks, dude. Thanks, bro. Thanks for
Going up here muffin. Yeah, we got it. [let] me go down and left
Yeah, you know the objective is sitting at a solid zero out of six. [I] love it though man wait
It's almost like you were giving me so much shit, and it's actually not [that] easy. I'm doing oh
Hope you hit a mountain way Donna
It's really bright in this mountain [it] would not be accurate to say that this is going well
Yeah, how do you mean don't question?
I'm not questioning
Aggressively, it doesn't feel good when you get questioned as the captain does it wait. Hey, enemy ship destroyed
Look, we did good it pretty [game-like] not on target for anything. I'm trying to get
Chips cuz you guys know my state of the mining outpost yeah
I guess we might as well take out the mining outpost. It does seem like it's one of our objectives. [I] don't know oh
So now the sun your Captain was not proud yeah, you're really that way don't left. You know, what wait
It was unfair of me to be so harsh on you
You're relieved you know I feel like togetherness is what we really want there. We go. Yeah
I feel like that's the message that we need to be spreading right now our core not not
How bad weight is doing? How good everyone is doing collectively balancing out? Whatever weight is a
Need a little [loud]. [it] was concentrate it was a compliment
Absolutely, not a lot of blasting
You who are your hearty parties?
It looked like just some like preteen kid took over captaining on our heroes ha ha ha
That was me I did [it] yeah, I
Got a beard in real life. Yeah. Look at our plate baby boy. He blew left to the end of his day
He [did]
Wow
Yes